my guest today is bert hubert he is a
software engineer by day
geneticist by night his work in genetics
has been published in nature
specifically in their multidisciplinary
journal of microbial ecology
he took interest in genetics because of
the parallels he noticed between the
genetic code and
assembly code and computing in fact he
was so blown away by the parallels that
he started a website
this was years ago pointing out all the
similarities this
ended up leading him to start
conversations with geneticists and
eventually
this blossomed into him doing actual
scientific research that's published in
nature
our discussion today was pre-recorded we
weren't able to match our schedules to
do a live show
but in it we talk about many things
including his encounters with
creationists who think that his work
pointing out the similarities between
computers and cells counts as evidence
of god
burt of course does not take that
creationist view
in our chat we focus a little bit on
what's known about the evolutionary
origin
of the genetic code but for the most
part we just focus on
how amazing it really is just
think about this for a second at the
very heart of biology
exists a true communication system genes
transmit messages which are received and
decoded
by ribosomes genes are molecules
ribosomes are molecules this is
insane molecules they have no minds they
have no
understanding of their own existence yet
they have evolved the ability to
communicate
scientists have discovered the
foundational rules of their strange
language
you can see those rules laid out in the
codon chart of the standard genetic code
these rules are nearly universal almost
every single organism uses
actually this exact same genetic code
there are some slight variations
many more rules that govern gene
regulation have been discovered on top
of this and these are oftentimes
species-specific rules and many more
rules
still wait to be discovered so hopefully
today you've got
an appetite for curiosity as i introduce
you to this fascinating man
who goes by bert bert hubert
welcome to sunday morning science bert
can you
tell us about your your background
briefly in computers and then the actual
research and the work that you did
in biology i studied physics originally
and i really loved that and that was the
time when the internet was really
booming
and 1997 and uh every bad idea got
founded as a company back then
and even my bad idea got founded as a
company back then
that's how i got into sort of running
software writing software that runs the
internet
these days around half of the internet
in europe and maybe 40
worldwide runs through software that i
wrote it's called powerdns.com
and you're not obviously aware but if
you buy a domain name somewhere chances
are that it's powered by my software
oh yeah yeah and um and it has been has
been
moderately successful as they say and uh
but for a while it was also not that
successful which meant i suddenly had a
lot of time on my hands
and sort of back in 2001
it was i ran into dna
and i read how these biologists were
talking about it and i thought well this
is
very fascinating stuff and obviously
these people are brilliant and they're
finding out many things
but they were i found that it was made
sense
to sort of apply my computer language
and world and study what they were doing
and see if it maybe also made sense to
look at it that way
yeah and you built a website about this
about you know that
looking at dna from a programmer's
perspective and you did two videos which
is is how i was introduced to your work
yeah the original uh website which is uh
it's still online
it's called amazing dna and
i wrote that and that was just my first
observations when i was reading through
the big dna
textbooks and i was like hey these
people they talk about codons
with codons and we'll get to that later
what they are but they're just like
bytes
and they have bits and these bits they
they make up those codons and
so i assembled all the cool things i
could find out about dna so
for yeah from a computer programmer's
perspective and i call that
the amazing dna page and actually stems
from 2001 so it's like
yeah it's it's all by now but it did
attract serious attention over the years
because
i i worded it carefully i said look dna
is not a computer language it is not a
computer but it still makes sense to
reason about it like that
and over the years many very serious dna
scientists would
chime in and say yeah well you got this
sentence a little bit wrong
and and this needs a little bit of
tuning or or i have this even more
amazing story that you should put in
there
um so over the years i finally sort of
came to realize that yeah maybe maybe i
am
onto something yeah maybe this is a
valid way of looking at dna
i've i actually first heard about you
from a creationist who's claiming that
your work proves that that god exists
because
the the cell is like a computer i get a
lot of email like that yeah
uh the the web page and the two videos
so in the end
the two videos came from a hacker
conference and that was sort of
honestly sort of a high point of my sort
of yeah
scientific life or whatever you would
call it but it was like i think 2 000
people listening to a story about dna
yeah and and that's good stuff and and
we overflowed the time and we had an
extra session where lots more people
showed up so people do really care
but i on average i get like one email a
month
from someone that sees the hand of god
in dna
yeah or mars or
atlantis uh there are many people that
sort of
see things in dna and they all send me
email yeah i did a video
last week on signaling theory which is
the theory in biology that explains how
it is that
signaling systems and communication
systems develop naturally
a lot of people are not familiar with
that and so when they see that there is
something that we can call code we
really can call a genetic code a code it
really does work like a computer code
that the parallels are insane there when
people see that and they don't
understand signaling theory they think
oh well
this must be some sort of intervention
by either an alien or
a intelligent designer and so on and
so that's been that's been a i've been
teaching evolution now
since 2012 online all my energy goes to
all my you know science education and
this has been a really this has been a
theme
in the comment sections of my videos and
emails people send to me
is that that because the genetic code is
a code
it had to have been designed therefore
aliens
or god or whatever the person happens to
believe in
and a lot of the online atheist
community
has been in the comments in my videos
too telling them no the
the genetic code has nothing to do with
a code it's just chemistry
the the codon chart is just the same as
the periodic table it's just a chart
showing molecules and and that's not
true
and so i i've been i've been seeing
these people argue back and forth
and it's just been every once in a while
i've tried to intervene there was
actually there was a
atheist youtube channel that does like a
weekly
show and you can call in and they had
just been
making fun of a guy for saying that the
genetic code actually works like real
code and so
i called in and tried to correct them
and they would not have it they'd shut
me down
they ended up like so it's it's really
weird that there's i mean i'm i don't
i'm not religious i don't believe that
aliens or gods
invented the genetic code it's really
weird to see that the atheist community
there's this obviously it's not the
whole atheist community but there's
this chunk of people in the atheist
community that are just trying to throw
away
the significance of the genetic code in
order to win
an argument or to to pretend that
they're winning an argument
and it's that it's unfortunate because
the genetic code is so
fascinating what's wrong well it's
utterly it's utterly awesome
i mean it's if you're seeking if you
look into it and you study it from time
to time you just go like
yeah this is just the most amazing thing
ever yeah
and then you maybe you eat a banana and
then you realize i'm eating this master
work
yeah and um and it is it is just
literally awesome in the sense that it's
full of it's it generates all
right and many people have and i think
that's the reason why
lots of people latch on to it also is
that yeah
it does instill that sense of wonder and
i
i have compared it in the past that
that's a let's say you you would live in
a house and suddenly
an alien spaceship would land in your in
your garden
and and aliens would walk out and it
would offer you the engineering manual
of their
spaceship yeah and that would be on the
same level
as of fascinating as the dna stuff we're
discovering right now
right because it really it is it is
machinery it powers life it powers
everything it takes decisions
it is it is us but it's not built
by us right so we see we see organisms
make
choices we even see bacteria deploy
strategies and we don't really know how
they do it and then we can go look in
the dna and there we find yeah your
survival strategy is encoded
in this glorious machinery yeah
which we have not built yeah it was
built by nature
and and there's there for me there's no
reason to to involve any
religion or stuff in that but it's it's
awesome enough that we have these these
problems solving
algorithms that we did not make yeah
yeah and
by a large we also do not understand uh
because we can apply a tremendous amount
of research and then we
understand a very small bit of it and uh
and that's awesome enough but we know we
we already know that
so every time we discover something as
human beings like a
control theory or whatever we find out
that it has been in
in nature for for 300 million years
already
everything we're going to discover in
the coming decades
is also already hiding out in there when
we invented pulleys and levers
that's already in our arms and hands and
fingers i mean that stuff's already
there
pretty much everything that we've we've
invented has been
has been there before i mean and in
spades so
so the classic control theory for
example is when you have a
big ship and and it needs to steer
itself to stay
on a certain heading and um if you're a
very nervous
guy you would constantly be steering to
keep the ship
exactly on the right heading but that's
expensive because it costs
fuel it costs attention and but there
was a task that were that that human
beings were uniquely good at
there was a very long time it was not
possible to automate this
right and then finally someone derived
the math to
to actually keep uh sort of keep a ship
on the right heading
with minimal interventions and they were
some nice differential equations
and then like decades later we find that
the ph levels
in our blood are governed by the exact
same equations and the exact same
mechanisms
but it has been there for like 200
million years yeah
and so yeah it's it's it's just yeah
it's full of awesome
no other way to go about it yeah so
today we're not going to really talk
about origins in general
of this stuff i've talked a little bit
about that in in other videos
i just want us to get just yeah
awestruck
by just the beauty of these systems
and really really try and understand
from you from a coders perspective uh
you know how this stuff relates to the
computer because i mean
it's an analogy to computers and cells
but the analogy
runs so deep that it's it's it's pretty
spectacular
and one of the things that i just wanted
to
to start with is what what is it that
people really mean when they talk about
computer code when they talk about code
in computers
the genetic code it was called the code
because that was in reference to like
you know the codes that
people would use in wartime to
communicate with each other secretly
and so when we cracked the genetic code
it was like cracking the germans code
they were using in world war ii
but what do we mean when we talk about
code in computers it exists on multiple
levels so
if we start down with the sort of the
lowest level in a computer
there is a central processing unit a cpu
yeah and that's the the lowest level
thing there is and also that's the
closest
part to dna that we actually see and it
executes code and the code it executes
is of the type
take these two numbers add them together
and if the result is bigger than 100
then jump to this
further bit of code and then execute
that okay so everything you do
boils down to such simple execute codes
that really does not
nothing more than adding numbers
comparing numbers
multiplying numbers storing them and and
maybe doing something
in case a certain condition is met is
this when we talk about ascii code that
zeros and ones is that yeah these are
this is actually even lower than ascii
code
these are really the zeros and ones so
if you really drill down to it
then a cpu takes like a collection of
ones and zeros
and based on 16 of these ones and zeros
it may it
does something or it does not do
something and this is the most
basic and that's not the right word
because that's actually a programming
language but it's the most fundamental
code
we have in a computer and if you go back
to sort of the
original chips so if you used to have a
commodore 64
for example in the past there was a chip
in there with
3 000 transistors which is a sort of
manageable number you could
you could have them with a little
electronics units that are like yeah
like like like this big they're really
tiny yeah
and you have 3000 of them and those
would already execute
this code and that's the most basic
stuff that we have
and if you look at people that write
javascript code that is also code
but it is actually converted
into these ones and zeros before it can
actually run
is there any human that can read that
stuff yeah oh yeah and there are people
and there are worrying people these
these are the scary hackers these are
the
the people you see on tv that hack into
into the pentagon or whatever those are
the people that can just
see those ones and zeros and they they
can they can not only figure out what is
going on but they can even see what this
is originally written in the following
computer programming language and
yeah it was probably compiled in 2005
because there's a sort of handwriting in
there where you can see yeah i can see
where this came from and
and what it is doing yeah um so that's
really really fascinating stuff
and the same goes for dna if you look at
the raw dna which is very
fun thing to do you can just download
dna
and then you will read it as four
letters a c
g and t so where computers have the
zeros and ones
dna has a c g and t and
much like if you look at the zeros and
ones it takes you an awful long time to
figure out what's going on
you can stare at dna all day long and
try to find
meaning in there and and sometimes you
can
sometimes there are for example there
are people that are so good
they can take a look at dna and say well
this came from
an e coli like bacterium right because i
spot patterns in there that are
typical of an e coli bacterium where it
is utterly fascinating that
the dna of bacteria or the
or viruses or us or plants and
cucumbers are the same and and
what you're saying but as there's not
there's not variation in the
rules of the coding system so the the
codon chart
yeah it is it's to the point that codes
will
in fact accidentally run yeah so
if a bacterium gets lost in the wrong
place then it's
it's it's dna code will get executed it
will get run will
have effect on human beings
and there's a few tiny variations and
but those only actually make it only
more interesting
yeah um because the varian will get to
that in in spades but the variations are
so
tiny and they all have reasons they all
have reasons where you can say oh i can
see i can see why that happened
the physical substrate that the genetic
code runs on top of is the ribosome
it's the messenger rna it's
this whole translation system all of
this is physical you've got chemical
reactions happening
these are evolved structures the rules
governing the genetic code emerged
from these evolved structures sometimes
people get this idea that code is
somehow different or that
information is somehow like this magical
thing that's
that's different than normal matter but
of course a computer actually runs
like all the information is stored in a
physical substrate
could you talk a bit about that physical
substrate in the computer what is
actually happening what are these zeros
and ones
really yeah yeah well actually so the
analogy is quite good again
so in computers actually the ones and
zeros they sort of travel
and they appear in different guises so
if they are on a rotating spinning hard
disk
which we all used to have and there the
information
resides in uh transitions in magnetic
poles between north and south poles
okay so a a zero is actually a
transition between the north and the
south pole
part of a disk and um but if it's in
flash
memory then your one is a bunch of 20 to
40 electrons
okay that sits there and it's trapped
there and it cannot leave that's why
flash memory
uh can work without power and we retain
your data for months and
actually we don't even quite know why
the electrons don't escape from there
but we're not asking because it works um
if it's in your computer memory in then
actually then
it's the same thing it's then it's a
charge the one and the zero but the
charge would leak out
in a very short time so there because it
leaks out all the time we have to keep
on putting it back in
so many times per second all your ram
memory gets visited
see is there a charge in here if so
let's top it up
yeah and and if there is no charge in
here then let's make sure that it's
empty
and um so depending on where
in the computer your information is it
is represented
in in different ways um
by the time it goes to the computer chip
it's purely a voltage and it's it's like
a mains voltage or not
and it's a few volt which is doesn't
sound like a lot
but because chips are so small these
days a small voltage
over a few nanometers is exerts more uh
charge differential than a bolt of
lightning so it's actually very
impressive that they're able to to
process these bits and bytes
through uh computers that are that small
without them
exploding so that's the physical nature
of it
and i try to to see if there if you
could make a parallel into the
efficiency of dna
and it's actually sort of uh quite
doable
sort of similar amounts of matter are
involved in
storing dna as in the physical memory
except that
dna is wound extremely tightly you you
could
store beta bytes of of data in dna in
like a like
in the tiniest drop of water and it will
also be pretty stable
so dna is really impressive but in all
in all the the analogies are
quite good a one and a zero is a
either a bunch of electrons or no
electrons or a magnetic charge
and if you look at dna it's it's one of
four molecules
which we call a c g and t which are
quite tiny molecules
and we can recognize them by the
different charge profiles
that they have which is again refers to
electrons
information is not some woo other
dimensional thing it is stored in matter
so in a computer this is through
electric pulses
or you know the these atoms inside of
these these disks
these polar charges and dna it's stored
in molecules i can take out the magic
further we can now
fully read dna and just store it on disk
and uh
and if you then look at the file you can
literally have a sort of chromosome
directory that has all these human
chromosomes in there
yeah uh if you then uh take a listing of
that file and sort it on order
you find that our chromosomes are
actually the numbers we assign to them
which is based on their sizes
so the fact that chromosome 1 is is
chromosome 1 is not because it's in any
way more important but just because it's
big
right but we can now go full circle you
can take
read dna from nature store it on disk as
a file which you can just inspect
and then you can send back that file to
a lab and they will turn that file back
into dna again
yeah yeah which is sort of the ultimate
way of taking the magic out of things
and saying yeah i could read it to you
over the phone
uh as a signal as a voice signal and
then people would put it in the dna
synthesizer and exactly the same thing
would come out
yeah so there's no there's no magic in
there
and people people get all hung up about
entropy and other stuff
and there's no more magic in in a piece
of dna than there is in a flash drive
right right and and i consider both to
be pretty magical in other ways but
it's it's not any woo-woo kind of magic
it's not it's very advanced technology
the physical substrate that dna is is
running on you know it's it's the
ribosome
and the transfer rna and there's a
there's a really neat
bit of research done on the ribosome it
has not
the the core of the ribosome there's
this tube inside the ribosome where the
the proteins come out as they're being
uh coated as they're being built that
has not changed
the width of an atom in all of life
so since since the ribosome came to be
it has not changed by a single atom in
that little core
there are lots of things if you look at
a human ribosome versus a bacterial
ribosome
there's lots of differences on the
outside there's lots of differences in
and how it attaches to messenger rna and
feeds that messenger rna through it but
at its very core there is
it's atom to atom identical which is
spectacular
there's nothing like that aside from the
ribosome in evolution
that has stayed so stable but it has a
good reason
you can actually compare that a little
bit to computing code there are
mistakes in computer science that we
that we made 30 years ago and we're
still dragging along those mistakes
because it by now if we want to fix them
now
then it's going to be terrible because
we would have to change
everything at the same time and since
we're not going to change
everything at the same time because
there's no way to coordinate that
we're not ever going to change it and
there are parts of dna that are just
like that that if you want to change
something really fundamental then all of
then the whole organism would have to
change
synchronously dna that used to work on
monday would not work on friday
right and that change is not gonna
happen and because it's not gonna happen
nothing has changed there yeah this is a
very strong analogy to the computing
world
where you just say yeah we're yeah it
sucks the way we built it sorry for that
and and we have to live with it now yeah
we've got liberty we have no idea live
with it we have
we are it now right right if you were to
do any major change to the genetic code
it would break
every single gene in an organism's body
so you'd have to
yeah you would have to edit every cell
everything yeah
and protein and yet we do we do some see
some
uh and i don't want to delve too much
into the the origins but
if you look at sort of the fingerprints
of dna and the way
the dna letters correspond to the amino
acids and the proteins
you can sort of derive that right now we
take three
dna letters and turn that into one amino
acid
but you can see that originally it was
probably two amino acids
and and one day life apparently decided
that
two was not quite enough and we needed
three
and life found some way to wiggle itself
into
three but from the architecture we can
make a good case that there are remnants
where you can say well originally it was
two
and and how that happened it's you can
you can reason about it but
that was sort of the biggest
architectural change
in life that ever happened yeah and that
that would have happened before
the most recent common ancestor of all
life because
because all living things share the same
genetic code
we can be very very confident that we
all share a common ancestor that was
using that code
and there's there there's arguments to
be made that
we should think of the common ancestor
really as the ribosome we don't know if
life was
cellular at that time yet we don't know
we don't know a whole lot about what was
going on maybe there was so much
horizontal gene transfer that
there were there were still like
packages and
these genes were getting in to you know
infecting other cell-like compartments
and so that that ribosome was the
the translation system was
the thing that really took over and
is our most recent common ancestor it is
and it is the most sort of
craziest piece um so it does the
conversion it takes these
three uh genetic letters and turns them
into an amino acid
and that's the most fundamental thing
there is and and
even though it is more or less the same
in the three
domains of life that still exist and
and indeed we know that they must have
been present in the two original
domains of life and and yet there's yeah
yet it's mostly identical
yeah just for clarity
for people listening that he said that
the the codon
makes an amino acid it doesn't actually
turn into an amino acid it's red
and uses the the ribosome uses that
to know which amino acid to grab out of
solution
and add to the growing protein so this
is really a it's it's a reading
system the messenger rna with these
codons on it these three nucleotides
they're that's being read by the
ribosome
and it uses that to know what to
add to the growing protein next you
order picker
yeah so it gets a list so you need to
take this amino acid you need to take
that amino acid and put them all
together
and then you get a protein and this is
why
i i'm so adamant about saying this is a
communication system
because you have a set of symbols that
the codon is not an amino acid it
represents an amino acid it is a symbol
that was selected these codons that we
have in the codon chart the classic
codon chart of the genetic code that was
cracked back in the
what is the i think it was the 70s that
they got the nobel prize for cracking
that code
this was selected by nature to be the
genetic code and it could have been
alternatives instead this really is a
communication system
so there are three codons that
correspond to one amino acid
and because there are four nucleotides
you will get four times four
times four is 64 possibilities yeah
but there are only like 20 amino acids
right
which means there are more ways of
saying the same thing
in dna and any time
you get that kind of freedom there there
are more ways of
saying the same thing you can get a
possibility for dialects
and what we find in nature is that
different strands of nature
have different preferred ways of
encoding the same
amino acid so some of them will always
use aac
to to describe alanine or whatever and
some of them will
use aag and those are dialects
and those dialects they they do not
break the compatibility in any way
but for example when the insulin hormone
was first made using
dna because the diabetic people need
that
and they took the the human genetic code
for insulin
and put that in a bacterium and told
them to go go run with it
and the bacterium dutifully did that and
it built insulin
and everyone was like yay nobel prize
actual nobel prize
yeah but but but it didn't the bacterium
did not was not in any hurry to do that
it was actually very slow it really was
like
people disappointed was not making a lot
of insulin
yeah which is of course nice you have
this revolution and then three weeks
later people say yeah well it's a bit
slow
um and then they looked at the codon
tables
for bacteria and for human beings and
they found out that
actually we were using valid dna for the
bacterium but the
the for the bacterium it was like we
were speaking a very heavy dialect
right because it was using codons that
are
frequently used in humans but very
infrequently in bacteria
yeah and then the the the code was
adjusted to the the bacterial dialect
and it went like three orders of
magnitude faster
which is the wow of two people both
speaking english but one with a very
heavy accent
right yeah they can still understand
each other but it's going to take more
time
yeah and then you adjust a few things
and then you're like oh that's what you
were saying
right um so and
but like so and i i find this utterly
fascinating again of course
but then we find out that this dialect
is actually also used
for a lot of things yeah um
because we now have discussed how how
you take a bunch of dna with codons and
that converts into amino acids and in
proteins
it's nice if you have a protein factory
but a protein factory is not yet life we
need to know
when to make what protein right
and and that is why you get to the core
of what the overlap between computer pro
programming and dna because you want to
have algorithms
right where you can have if statements
that say
if there is a lack of glucose then make
the following protein
or if there is too much glucose then
produce
insulin and those it took it took a long
this is where the biologists are really
it's sort of
i love my biologists because many of
them will be watching this i love my
biology friends
i really do but when i see them write
about
uh algorithms in dna it's it's
sort of sad to see because they're
they're this it's like someone that
cannot cook
who is describing how to cook an egg
yeah uh
and they really and whereas we as
computer people we go like
yeah i see an if statement there right
and
uh where we can see pieces of dna that
are turned on
under certain conditions and here's
where it sort of gets magical
uh dna needs to get activated under
certain conditions
and there are many ways of doing that
but
to do that dna needs to have certain the
dna itself needs to have a certain
charge distribution
it needs to have a certain physical
shape but if you look at purely the code
itself
and let's say every codon corresponded
to one amino acid
yeah you would not have any freedom to
shape dna
in any way dna would always be the same
would be only one way to describe
insulin in dna but because we have so
many different ways
of encoding the same amino acids
you can maintain the amino acids
of insulin but change the dna such
that it will curl up in a very
interesting shape
right and we can do that because of
these dialects
and there you see a very big difference
between computer code
and dna code when someone programs a
computer it doesn't matter if they add
spaces to it or empty lines
or or whatever the code is the code
but for dna actually the way it is
written very much determines
how it will be run yes there is metadata
in the signal
so you're saying that the the sequence
in a genome
not only is that used by the ribosome to
build protein
but it's also used by packaging proteins
inside the
the nucleus of the cell in our case or
just inside the bacteria
to wrap up that dna and package it in
different ways
yeah so that it will get activated or so
that it will
rarely get activated or so
the the shape of the dna determines when
it will get activated
and then the contents of the dna will
determine what happens then
yeah what protein comes out yeah i'm
going to show on screen here
an image from david goodsell which his i
don't know if you've seen his work he
does these
paintings of the inner workings of the
cell absolutely spectacular but
in this bacteria we can see that the the
dna is all wound up there's a bunch of
different proteins that are stuck to it
and they're causing it to kink in
certain ways and to bend in certain ways
and those proteins they have an affinity
to certain sequences
in the genome that they attach to and so
not only does the sequence of the genome
matter for coding for proteins but it
also
attracts these molecules to attach to it
and change
how tightly bound or how loosely bound
it is and that determines
how much that chunk of the dna will
actually be read
and used and so this is for this is for
gene regulation
and it's not clear that the first
organisms would have had
something like this would be something
that that evolves gradually over time
and adds
becomes an advantage to it to certain
organisms over others you
talked specifically about the if else
statement in bacteria for
digesting lactose which was the first
one that we discovered
the first switch that we found this is
like right after world war
ii is was in in bacteria yeah so it's a
it's the textbook case
yeah so this is where and and it tells
you so much about
biology so there are bacteria and they
they run bacteria and need a lot of food
to run on and they need it all the time
because bacteria don't have big bellies
or whatever they just need
the food needs to come in right now and
they can run on different kinds of
molecules most of them are
sugar related like human beings they
need to have a certain concentration of
these
sugars in their system because otherwise
they don't function
right and the same thing for for for
human beings and they need to regulate
that
and it was sometimes biology let's just
latches on to one sort of mechanism or
organism that says we're going to
study this until our eyes bleed right
and find out everything we can about
this particular mechanism
and this one was picked called the luck
operon
i could talk you could talk about it i
made a joke that this is sort of the
elementary particle of
of biology it's sort of the simplest
thing we even call it an
operon which sounds a bit like a higgs
boson or whatever yeah so we try to
really understand it as a sort of the
simplest
unit we can find and in the simplest way
you would say well if the glucose
concentration becomes too low then it
starts to
convert lactose into glucose so there
could be an if statement that says
if not a lot of glucose then build
lactose
or then convert lactose into glucose and
it turns out the reality
even though this is the net effect of
this piece of dna the actual reality is
like
nothing like this because it's so messy
so it what it actually senses
is that as long as glucose is being
transported into the cell
there is a sort of waste element that
builds up and the moment it's no longer
entering the cell
that waste element stops building up and
the whole process actually senses a lack
of that waste product i particularly
like this example because it
shows you there is no intelligent
designer be like behind this algorithm
it's a neat it's it works it's the
algorithm is fine it
achieves the goal it regulates glucose
it does that really
well but it does it in an incredibly
stupid way
uh or yeah i cannot argue with the
success it's massively successful there
it might even have advantages but it's
it's not the intuitive thing that anyone
would ever do
you would we would as human beings we
would if you want to regulate glucose we
would build a glucose sensor
and then regulate glucose and that's not
what nature has done nature has
made the sensor that actually measures
this other stuff
and and the way it measures that is
actually that's how these proteins do
their work
proteins are these these smaller or
larger molecules and they can they can
bend they can
they can be like this or they can be
like this or they can
ball up or they can stretch out in their
stretched out form they might not
stick to a bit of dna but let's say
it changes it bends then suddenly it
might stick to dna
and the actual glucose sensor or the
waste product sensor
is a molecule that that switches shape
based on the concentration
of that the waste element and the moment
it switches
shape it manages to attach to dna right
and there it will then promote a certain
gene to do things
but it's even smarter than that because
it makes no sense to start con
converting lactose into glucose if there
is no lactose
so it's actually a dual if statement
that says only do this thing
if there's a lack of glucose and we have
lactose
then you can do this thing and i'll
round it off by saying that we
we people really happy with this sort of
elementary particle of biology called
the luck operon and by now i have found
that there are complexities
layered on complexities on complexities
and even this
most fundamental thing we found you
could probably write a thousand page
book
literally only on this aspect let's try
and clarify this again
it's kind of hard without without
visuals here so the part that i've
studied most is the
the thing that senses lactose so if
there's
it's a protein that sticks to the dna
and stops it from being used
so inside the bacteria you've got a
string of dna which codes for an enzyme
that can process lactose and there is a
protein stuck to that gene
that stops it from being used but if
lactose
is in the cell it attaches to that
protein causes that protein to change
its shape and it falls off
the string of dna and so that that can
allow that gene to start being used
it's a beautiful system because the gene
is turned off
when there's no food for it to digest so
if you if you were to try and think of
of the origin of something like this
having the machinery and constantly
running it it'd be like uh let's say
that you had a fast food chain
and you had restaurants all over the
country and like three cities went vegan
you had no way to know that and so you
just kept running your burger joint in
those cities and you made no sales and
you had no feedback
and so you just kept doing it you could
probably survive if you
if your chain was big enough by just
losing these stores and running them at
a loss and that's what that's what a
that's what a bacteria that would
constantly make this lactose enzyme
would be doing they'd be constantly
running at a loss
they'd be making this protein for no
reason it would
it would be produced it'd spend up a
bunch of energy
being produced it would bounce around in
the cell then and get digested
eventually
and recycle it actually actually it's
even worse bacteria live
in constant competition right right now
because they
exponential growth is the name of their
game and the only one that survives is
the one that grows
quickest and the moment and because
bacteria can double themselves in like
20 minutes or something like that
and let's say you reduce your doubling
time to 19 minutes because you're just
slightly more efficient
using energy after a day you dominate
everything
because you've made a few more copies
during the day than the rest so
bacteria that are less than perfectly
efficient they they lose
they would be winning before that enzyme
evolved
but but as soon as that enzyme evolved
if you don't have that enzyme you lose
so yeah so in biology experiments with
bacteria and they're like really fun to
do because
biology is really messy and and and it's
not fun to do
if you if you know any biology is doing
experiments with the zebra fish or
fruit flies or whatever they're these
are truly heroes
because these are experiments that mess
with you but bacteria
is very simple and what you a very
typical experiment
is that you take a petri dish which is
like a piece of glass
and you put only one kind of food in
there
for bacteria and which is the food that
they don't really like
and then you inoculate that with with
one kind of bacteria you put it
in the dish and they start growing
slowly because it's not
the it's they're they're feeding on pure
lactose which they don't like
so the bacteria don't grow that quickly
and then
within a real really short time frame
and it can happen in one day
one of your bacteria discovers how to
more efficiently break down
the foods you gave them and that one
literally launches a new plume of
bacteria
that grows far far faster than all the
other ones
so you can literally see them figure out
okay you gave us the wrong food
and we've evolved our way out of this
and boom now we grow five times quicker
and we end up dominating the entire
plate
yeah and the really cool thing about
that is that you can actually go through
and find the mutation that caused that
that change and in many cases yeah i
know
it's textbook and i think everyone it
used to be the people like yeah is
evolution real
well bacteria people they say yeah
evolution is very real
and by now it is so real that it messes
with your experiments
so if you're trying to learn something
about bacteria
what biologists now do they do the
experiment with the bacteria
and then immediately put them in the
freezer again
to just stop them from evolving so the
into the minus 80 they go
and then when we do another experiment
we briefly take them out of the minus 80
celsius so that they can do another
experiment because otherwise they will
out evolve your experiment they will
they will no longer you will not learn
anything
uh yeah you will learn that evolution is
a thing
so you have some slides here and uh yeah
i'd like to just
let you go through that uninterrupted so
this is briefly
the the luck operon that we discussed
before which is this this
if statement and what it will do
is it says if there is glucose in the
cell then use the glucose in the cell
if there is no glucose in the cell and
if there is lactose then start
converting the lactose
into glucose and if there is new clothes
no glucose and no lactose then
do nothing bacteria are quite good at
doing nothing
in case they have no energy and that's
the third option
so on the lower right of the screen you
will see typically
how a computer programmer would
represent these three choices
and on the top you see the lac operon
which is the
nature implementation
of this algorithm and you see on the
left
you see a thing called promotes rna
polymerase binding and then you see cap
and cap is the sort of side product that
we mentioned that that sort of tells the
cell that hey we're running out of
glucose
yeah and if that one is present it will
latch onto the dna so that bar you see
that says
capsid and promoter and operator
that is actually a piece of dna yeah and
the moment it needs to become active
this cap thing attaches to
the dna and it attracts the rna
polymerase
which says i'm going to read this bit of
dna now right so that's one part of it
it said
do this stuff if there is a lack of
glucose then try to
read this dna right and then more on the
right you see a thing called a repressor
and the repressor makes sure that
this only works as long as the repressor
is attached to the dna
the cell can physically not read it
right then it blocked the the whole
assessing thing is blocked so there's a
promoter at the beginning that says yes
please
and then there is a repressor that says
no and this combination
if there is actually no lactose present
then the repressor attaches to the dna
right so and the net effect of these two
is that if there is a lack of glucose
then the system wants to read the dna
but that will fail unless there is
lactose present
right because if there is no lactose
then the repressor attaches
and nothing happens so this is a very uh
this is as close as you're going to come
to actually seeing the equivalent of
computer codes with if statements
expressed in biology right
this this is really amazing so just
again to clarify this the the the bar
here that says caps
it starts with saying capsite that
represents the
the dna if there's plenty of sugar then
this whole thing
nothing is attached to it well i guess
we would have a repressor attached
if there's plenty of sugar and no
glucose and so this gene would be turned
off
nothing the rna polymerase which needs
to hit that gene
and convert it into rna so that that
that rna can then
make protein that will not happen so as
long as there's
good glucose in the cell this doesn't
get used at all if there's no glucose
then that cap gets added on there
allowing rna polymerase
to start trying to do its job to make
rna and then
make protein but if there's not lactose
that repressor is going to be attached
there stopping it from doing its job
and only when both of those conditions
are met will it make this
that is absolutely beautiful and
the interesting thing is that we have
all cells use the same dna
but this if else statement it evolved in
bacteria
and it's its own thing and we have a
bunch of these
in human cells as well but they have
different evolutionary histories
they function differently and like
scientists have to
discover how each of these things work
independently because a lot of them are
completely different
but we have these if else statements all
throughout biology
and there are two interesting things and
there are like a thousand interesting
things here but
actually nature does a little bit better
than the simple if statement because
it's an if statement that also
carries a sense of urgency right so the
the bigger the lack of glucose the the
more intense
the dna transcription will be and so
this is like an if statement that not
only says if glucose is present then use
glucose
but it will also say look we're like
really out of glucose so get on with it
yeah it modulates it and
you mentioned the human equivalent and i
also
find that part fascinating bacteria are
within
our realm of understanding we can sit
down and study this and read it and
actually you could you could print this
bit of dna
out and you could study it you could
annotate it with a pencil
and really get it yeah
plant dna and and fungi dna
and human dna is like three orders of
magnitude
more complicated right so instead of
only having one
uh um uh operon there isn't
there is a layer on top of that that
that cascades that says
now this subsystem is active or not
and that is when you when you study that
it is
it is possible to study it and we we we
get we do make progress there that's how
we develop medicines and other stuff
but there is like bacteria when then you
go back to bacteria and you go like hey
i can just understand this stuff pen and
paper yeah yeah
and um and the final thing i find
utterly fascinating about this so you
have this
stretch of dna with the capsid and the
operator
and and then there are these genes the
lac z
and lac y and they are actually bunched
together
so these are a bunch of genes that have
independent functions
but they are all bunched together here
so they can get turned on and turned off
in unison right together so so this is
like where you have a bunch of documents
and you put them
all in one directory all in one folder
because they make sense together
right and that's a sort of very sort of
yeah you can recognize that you would
like a computer programmer would also
put a bunch of functions in one file
because yeah they're related and it's
sort of easier to keep them together
sometimes
you spot and dna this sort of ordering
where things are sort of
that actually sort of do do something
with each other are also
collocated with each other which does
not specifically have to be the case
you could have two genes that are
intimately involved with each other and
they could be on opposite ends of the
dna
or random places but sometimes you see
them grouped together where you realize
yeah apparently there is some some
benefit
of having these together and here the
benefits of course obvious because
otherwise they would not get turned on
in unison but in other cases
it almost feels like yeah they we have
to find the reason
why there's a phenomenon called genetic
hitchhiking which can explain these
things
but it ends up in a sort of very human
familiar organizational structure yeah
yeah yeah maybe it would be good to talk
a little a little bit about um
about how genes can actually move around
within a genius they do
this happens it's a common form of
mutation
and so finding finding the finding a
good neighbor is almost
as important as the actual sequence of
the gene so
that does happen over evolutionary time
yeah it does
and to the point that the majority the
vast majority of
human and plant dna consists of elements
that have been copying themselves
uh for no good reason right right
which is and if you've ever taken a look
at the code
of a big computer project i mean if you
ever download a computer program or a
game and you wonder why
why is this game 25 gigabytes right uh
what happened there that's because if
you would study it you would find that
you're downloading a lot of copies of
copies of the same thing that never got
removed from the project
yeah and um well welcome to biology
is exactly what happens in biology where
no
every gene has a few dying copies lying
around
or failed experiments and they get
cleaned up so slowly
that that we carry with us the entire
history and trauma of like a billion
years of evolution
yeah yeah so so people probably heard
the term junk dna which is falling out
of fashion because
we're finding so much function in the
supposed junk dna but you've got
pseudogenes which are genes that that
should code for protein but are broke
and organisms will still have them we've
got a bunch of
humans have a bunch of um scent
pseudogenes so our nose
is super weak compared to other primates
because a bunch of our
smelling genes are broken so they're now
pseudo genes
and evolution just hasn't cleaned them
up yet maybe because there's
you know something else in them that's
still important for folding up the dna
and so on maybe
maybe evolution can't get rid of them
because there's something beneficial in
them still
and yeah you see that everywhere and
then you have these jumping genes which
are these stretches of dna that can just
make copies of themselves pull
themselves out of where they're they're
located
move themselves sometimes they move a
chunk of their neighbor as well
and we're our genome is loaded with
those and we
think that those were important for
organizing our genome and they can cause
chaos sometimes when they get out of
hand
and it so yeah it's it's it's such a
mess
it's such a mess yeah it is a mess but
it is an inspirational mess
yeah so it's a lot like if you again go
back to computer programmers
um we will often also not read let's say
there's a
function functionality in code that we
no longer need
right now right but we might feel that
like yeah but maybe one day
maybe we don't need it now so let's keep
that file around
and but even though we don't use it
right so the file is still there
and because maybe one day we feel like
we could use it again
and then we and all every software
project is is full of this stuff
but then one day you realize you need
that code again and hey it's still there
right and and then you can revive it and
then you find even in in programming and
this this phenomenon is very real and
puzzling
let's say you took a bit of code and you
didn't use it for two years
but in theory nothing should have
happened to that code
in two years time if you try to use it
again there's a phenomenon called bitrot
and that's the very real phenomenon
where you take this two
two year old piece of code nothing
changed to it still it no longer works
is that because there's a good reason
being changed no yeah
the surroundings have changed so the
piece of code turned out so the code did
not change
but let's say it relied on something it
relied on
files always being given to the system
in the same order
whatever the hidden assumption and over
time
that assumption has been violated and
the the files now get presented
in a different order which should make
no difference but your code was relying
on the
some files coming first so after a few
years your code you revive it you start
using it again and nothing works and
then you're like hey did
has this skull be mutating while i
wasn't looking that's what it feels like
feels like you're a
fungus growing on your coats but it's
actually bit rotting
and the same phenomenon happens in in
biology as well that if you see these
old copies
of genes that are lying around we can
study them because
so here's another dark secret and and
this
really fascinates me in bacteria you can
see
where a gene begins and ends very well
because there's a real
marker that says the gene begins here
and it ends here and it's even more
luxurious than that you get a warning
that says the gene is about to end
and that's because the polymerize has to
get off again
it needs an exit ramp so at the end of a
bacterial gene you see the little exit
ramp
and then you see the actual end so it's
very easy in the bacterium to see where
a gene begins and ends
very much like in a computer program
when we look at the ones and zeros we
can find the
beginning of a function and the end of a
function because it has a certain
structure to it in more
advanced or complicated organisms like
plants
and us the beginning and ending of a
gene is
we cannot find it we we really have no
idea where a gene begins and ends
nature has a fantastic way of finding
out where a gene begins and ends and
it's perfect at it
and we haven't figured out how nature
does that the only way we can figure it
out is by
looking what nature does and then saying
well apparently the gene begins here
when we do that we get a list of okay
these are the active genes
these are the ones that actually work
right and for every gene we find like 25
copies lying around
of older versions of the gene miscopied
things
and that allows you to do a whole
analysis to say okay apparently this
genius
is an old copy of the other one how much
has changed
right and and that allows you sort of
complete forensic historical
analysis of how a gene has evolved over
the years so it's like having this
gigantic archive where every email you
ever read is still there
yeah and all the drafts are also there
you're saying that um sometimes when you
turn code back on it breaks
it doesn't work right we have atavisms
in evolutionary biology so you've got
like
you know sometimes people will will be
born with a tail
or a horse will have uh you know horses
only have one toe
sometimes they're they're they'll have
three toes
and it's always a monstrous deformity
because you've got this thing that got
turned back on again
but everything else around it changed
and so now you just cut this
weird it's usually a disability that
ends up happening
but it could go the other way around you
you mentioned the the the primates
that compared to primates our sense of
smell is so much weaker which
i didn't know i find fascinating but
let's say we had a
pressing evolutionary need to to get
back our superior sense of smell
uh evolution would quite quickly sort of
rediscover these defunct genes lying
around
and maybe accidentally enable one and
create some quite miserable people that
now suddenly have a tremendously good
sense of smell which they didn't want
uh i know but but you find that these
old genes they're they're sort of there
for the reactivating they are actually
going to mutate over time the longer
something's going to be off so
it's definitely easier for evolution to
turn something on
and then mutations will edit it and
start to make it work with the current
system
over time than it would be to invent a
whole new gene right
and actually we use this to figure out
if a gene
if a gene is important then defects in
it will
uh will get fixed or they will not
spread if a gene is not being used it
will just accumulate errors at a known
rate
right and from that we can even
determine how long ago
uh how many millions of years ago or
tens of millions of years a gene
became defunct because we know that yeah
there is now there are now
12 there's now 12 error rate in there
uh and we know from from experience that
it takes 100 million years for that many
hours to crop up
yeah and there there are a lot of
experiments um
i'll probably try and link to some
papers here where people will uh
they'll break a gene and then see how
long it takes evolution to fix it
and get it back up and running and
yeah it's really interesting to watch
this happen because
you can break it in the lab using lab
techniques and then you watch
slowly mutation by mutation you watch
the cell try to fix it
sometimes it'll just completely throw it
away it never finds a way to fix it
again
because it's it's a stochastic process
it's random
and sometimes let me let me let me tell
you something that i only learned
recently let's say you disable an
important looking gene
yeah super important and i'm just gonna
ruin it
and quite often nothing happens and
because it turns out that the work of
that gene was not done by that gene
alone there were two other genes that
were also doing something similar but
together
right um so we we sometimes fall into
this trap where we think that this gene
is like the gene four right right and
it turns out that it's not true in two
ways for one it's not the only gene
for and so like the the the gene for
blue ice maybe i'm just
i'm just making this up this is not
factual but uh
it's if you then look it up you find out
that the gene for blue eyes actually
does
three other things as well and there and
there are also two other genes that
together
also make blue eyes right um and that is
in stark
contrast to to how we think that these
things work that you have
the gene that that gives you x or
whatever
and there is actually sort of analogy
also in the computer world computer
programs tend to be far more fragile so
if you
take out one function then your whole
computer stops working
it's quite rare for a computer program
to say well i'll limp on
sometimes there are you could for
example have multiple computer programs
that have the same effect
one of them defragments your files and
the other one cleans up all the files
and maybe
together they both have a defragmenting
effect
as an example that's more of the analogy
you should be looking at
yeah so i i work with a lab and
corvallis that does
gene knockout experiments well they
designed a molecule that people use for
gene knockout experiments
and they found that these are used in
zebrafish they found that for the most
part if you knock out a gene
in sperm or egg it sometimes won't even
have an effect because
yeah other genes will compensate for
that loss but if you knock out a gene
as it's developing then it will break
the it'll break the uh
the embryo so yeah there's a bunch of
just
backup systems and backup systems and
and we keep on discovering
i mean i i when i'm in the philosophical
mood i
i sometimes wonder if if if there is not
so much complexity in there that we'll
never discuss
that will never discover all of it yeah
so we know for example that in in animal
genomes during the the developmental
phase
as you noted there's actually sort of qa
run
that happens on dna and where all genes
get
reactivated because the other one is not
active right
so there is a sort of trial run going on
during the
the embryo phase where defunctive genes
are sort of papered over and say well
not you please yeah
and other ones that can then yeah get
reactivated or become more important
and that's why i sometimes think that
our our
own brains may not be capable of
understanding the full complexity of our
own genome
much in a way that the computer may also
not reason about its own existence but
the bacteria are definitely within
within our sites we could definitely
understand bacteria
i like to to say that trying to
understand our own biology is kind of
like a dog
trying to swallow itself that last bite
is just too hard
no there there is there is no guarantee
that sort of the
that a brain will be able to to
understand its own genetic makeup
right no it doesn't have to be that way
right and
and since it's like this four billion
year old software project there's an
ample room for
complexity to creep in i i was talking
to a geneticist who studies dog
morphology and the way that he studies
it is he just
he looks for a trait and then he looks
for all the dogs that have that trait
and he sequences their genomes and he
looks for similarities and differences
and then he tries
he uses statistics to pinpoint i think
this is the mutation
and then they can genetically engineer
and put that mutation in a dog and see
if it's true
it's trial and error we are blind it's
so cool we are very
very much so but we are making progress
there because it used to be
the idea was that every trait would
correspond to one place in dna
and then we found out that that wasn't
true but in the meantime a million
papers have been written about how
this and this genetic defect gives you
that and that illness and it turned out
to mostly not be true
but now we have the statistical prowess
to figure out that say look if you have
this genetic change over here
and that one over there and that one
over there
then together that likely means that you
have a have blue eyes
or whatever right and that is now
statistically becoming feasible and it
never used to be feasible because just
the computational stuff you need to to
calculate that
um it is a lot of work um and and that
will
actually finally make dna more useful
because right now
actually when the the human genome
became
was finished and it's actually now
almost finished it has been almost
finished for the past 20 years but
we're not really getting there and um
that has not been the boon
that people thought it would be we have
not really been able to say okay
you have this dna and you should do that
and
um and maybe i think we're now getting
somewhat closer to being able to do that
because we
understand the interactions uh between
mutations on different genes and
different chromosomes now
hopefully someone doesn't use it for
evil first
too easy to make a disease um i would
that would turn this into a very
different
episode uh but i i am
yeah i'm not happy i'm i'm not confident
that this
will not go wrong yeah it's terrifying
that you can actually
order a stretch of any dna online
and it'll get mailed to you so yeah
if you know the code and we've got
pathogens
their dna is up on the internet what
else we have here
in slides yeah we discussed this a
little bit so what is in our dna
actually yeah
and it it's tremendous fun to do this
uh and we should also do this for
computer programs because like i said
whenever you update
a computer game and it's downloading 20
gigabytes of stuff
you may wonder what am i downloading
here yeah and um
when you do the analysis on on the human
genome
uh although this this works just as well
on dogs and cats or whatever
um you see the the little piece of the
pie in red
the protein coding genes so those are
the action bits
the bits where we say look these are
really
pieces of dna that we see end up in
proteins and
it used to be like you said rather
common to denote to tell the rest yeah
the rest of dna is just junk
and partially we know that it's not true
but from a very significant part we do
know that yeah this
this was not put in here for our direct
benefit right so for example these
ltr retro transposons those are just
copy happy bits of dna that
were shaped in a way that when they when
the dna gets copied sometimes you get
two of them right and that leads to a
disaster because that leads to a gene
that is gets selected gets evolved to
make even more copies of itself yeah
because if it succeeds in shaping itself
so that instead of one copy you get two
copies one next time you get four
so there is massive evolutionary
pressure on genes to
make themselves make themselves copy
yeah
more than one hundred percent and from
the
history of various genomes we see that
in some animals that this has really led
to disasters
yeah and it's a parasitic stretch of dna
it is we don't we don't need it there's
no and but
there is a theory however that says that
since
almost no organisms have excised
this this unnecessary dna and it
probably has some benefits and
so one of my own bad theories and i
hasten to say that it's just a theory
and a
hypothesis is that let's say you take
dna and 97
of that dna actually does not lead to
proteins
right and and then you are a virus and
the whole the holy grail for every virus
is to infect our germline
right become part of our future
and you know as a virus have a 97
chance of infecting a random bit of dna
that will never go anywhere
right and that is in a way sort of
defensive structure where you say well
you can attack my dna but
chances are you won't hit anything yeah
whereas if you infected bacterium
uh bacteria are like 90 of their dna
is actually active yeah so whatever
piece of
bacterial dna you hit you are in there
forever
um so it might be that it's like when
you have a secret to height
that you hide it in a room with lots of
other papers and you go like well good
luck finding my secret
yeah it's it's here in this pack for
mess unfortunately hiv
has a trick for that it uh yeah it
attaches itself to
uh i think it's rna polymerase and it
attaches it's got an enzyme that
attaches it to that and then
inserts itself right in front of the
polymerase so it's
it's it makes sure to always insert
itself in an active part of your genome
yeah
yeah well done yeah the
the viruses have hacked that that
defense if that is a defense they've
some of them have found a way to hack it
yeah and i think actually it is a
defense because
as i said we struggle as human beings we
struggle
mightily when we look at at human dna
to find where a gene begins and ends
yeah with supercomputers we struggle we
don't
and i interpret that as not an accident
but as a way for genes to hide
themselves and say hey you cannot find
me
yeah uh because we're cleverly hidden
um some way but i know this is just my
my pet theory um
maybe i'm right the the introns slice of
the pie so that's the 26 percent
yeah uh it's interesting to look at if
you look at a gene that is active
it has parts that end up in proteins and
then in the middle of a gene
there are all stretches and they're like
far larger than the actual gene
yeah there are whole stretches that say
well you should read this dna and you
should
copy this dna into rna you should do
everything with it
except turn it into proteins right
so these introns they they sit there
they faithfully get turned into rna that
rna gets destroyed again
and there is so much of that stuff
going on that that we we are
we are starting to understand maybe what
it's for what it's not for
but one very interesting thing is is
that
and this also happens in computers
actually sometimes in computers you need
to delay
something so something should not happen
a thousand times or a million times per
second this is only
happen at the slower rate and one of
these ways of achieving that is making a
computer count from 1 to 10 million
because it will it will take some time
to do that and that means that
the thing that is happening will not
happen as much because it spends time
counting to one million every time and
we have
one uh gene that's the longest gene
in the human body
which is associated with the dystrophy
and that gene is like 99 insurance
it's it's like a million a million
pieces of
genetic letters sprinkled all over that
protein
and that means that making that single
protein making that one molecule takes
like half a day
right simply because it's so much work
and the act the average cell will
actually also
literally have one copy of that molecule
and it will never run away because
making it takes half a day
yeah and that that may be the crude way
in which nature has said well look this
is a very unpopular
molecule and we don't ever want you to
make a lot of it that's why we stuffed
it full of these introns that you have
to read
to get to it and
then it fills your whole cell with bits
of rna that are not used
which again probably has a reason but
it's not something we've figured out yet
yeah it's really
interesting to see how much inside the
cell gets
built and then immediately broken down
again it's
i mean things are getting digested as
they're getting built in some cases
it's really not there there is a whole
metabolism uh
going on there and that metabolism is
very rapid
and and efficient and and make sure that
the cell is
is i mean the other thing to realize is
that that
cells will happily uh at least in our
body sacrifice themselves
they have no no there's no pride
attached to that because you can make
new cells
and it took me a little while to to
realize that because this
the cell in a mammal is such an uh
cathedral
of complexity and capability that is
sacrificing one that
yeah that feels like a waste of yeah
yeah how could you how could you yeah he
built this thing
and uh but then of course with the whole
corona virus
thing we i started trying to understand
the human
immune system and it turns out that we
just kill cells if they look the wrong
way
yeah if we when when we're not sure
about the cell
the human body just kills it says well
you can we can make other ones
yeah um but yeah but otherwise the
efficiency is just
astounding every part is used for
something
yeah yeah it is really fascinating i
mean just to think that
people make babies on accident all the
time
[Laughter]
and it is the most complicated thing
ever but we just do it on accident
because we're so i mean
sometimes i just sit so like i said
sometimes you just sit there and i'm
eating a banana and i'm like wow
[Laughter]
all this glory and and the whole infra i
mean if you realize that the cell has
these these these
vesicles and these factories and so if
the cell makes a protein but the protein
still has to go somewhere so there is an
address label attached to it
which is part of which is which is then
used to get the
insulin molecule to the right place
where the address label is stripped off
yeah and then the cell gets then it gets
further assembled and you're like
oh man this is just yeah
yeah it's it is amazing yeah
and the complicated chemistry
and you know engineering that evolution
did to allow you to pick your nose
is just spectacular i mean i mean
it's it's not i mean biology is actual
biologists because i'm just a pretense
biologist
but uh they they you alluded to this
earlier that there is this this magic
sense of awe
where we go like look this stuff is like
so so amazing
yeah and then in the next sentence we
have to say yeah but it's all fully
i mean it's completely logical it's
science and we will figure this out
and it's fully understood we fully
understand how all of this works because
we have to say that
because the moment we say that we are in
awe of this
miracle of biology then there is a whole
group of people god like you
you admit it's a miracle and and
it's tricky to to strike that balance i
know we know we can understand all of it
we have the blueprints we can understand
it it just requires
work to understand it but at the same
time we are just super in
awe yeah of this magical technology
which is not magical at all it's just
like like arthur c clarke said that
any any advanced form of technology is
indistinguishable of magic
right and until you understand it then
you go like okay
i get it now i get what's going on and
i'm still in all
right and and and this is the thing that
has kind of bothered me with the
the online atheist community is that
people are wanting to it seems like
they're wanting to dumb it
dumb things down and make it oh things
aren't that fascinating they're not that
special
but no like i mean they are the thing
the thing that gave rise to your
mind and your ability to to think and
and behave in this
of course it's spectacular it's it has
to be the most spectacular thing that
you'll ever study
it's it's really unfortunate that people
give in to this this idea that if if you
let yourself be in
awe you're opening up the door for women
yeah and i don't i don't think that has
to be the case at all no
and then i i i am here in europe i have
the good news is that it's not very
not as polarized here right um
but even here the moment i would go out
and say look i
uh we don't and so there is there are a
few biologists that just go out and
there
say it and say look yeah we don't know
where all this came from yeah we're
searching for it
and we we see we see the process the
process is logical
but there are still steps where we
really don't know and and and it's it's
important for scientists to be able to
admit that
and uh and and to even say look and the
the
some of the things that we will find
will be will be awesome
yeah and hard to believe and the risk is
then is that the moment you admit that
they say aha
evolution has failed whereas evolution
is like i said so real that you see
it happening during your experiment even
when you don't
when you're not set out to prove
evolution well evolution this
proves it proves it to you it's there
and yet if you look at
the whole set of dna it is so so awesome
that at this stage you cannot say that
we understand exactly where it came from
and that we can explain every bit of it
that is not true by a long shot
hopefully i will have some people who
are experts in the ribosome
on eventually but the yeah the origin of
the ribosomes and and
and the translation system we have
that is where the magic happens and i
mean if you would tell me if you would
tell me look we we
i mean we just sent a whole yesterday
humanity sent a new robot to mars to do
investigations
and if someone puts a dna sequencer on
mars and turns it on and finds
dna i would not be surprised are you
still you're saying dna from an original
an original origin yeah from from just
where we would say look dna
maybe we did not invent dna here maybe
we didn't maybe maybe it existed already
okay yeah i'm not saying that that has
to be the case but let's say we send the
dna sequencer to mars
and it finds dna there then we're like
yeah well i'm not surprised
and i'm saying this because it will
probably happen within our lifetimes
that we send the dna sequencer to mars
so it's always good that if you make
if you say i'm not surprised it's always
good to say that before it happened
because otherwise it doesn't count uh
but there is a black hole there we don't
we see that the glory
we see like i said we see the sort of
vestigial
patterns that the codon used to be maybe
two dna letters
you see hints of that which would create
a simpler ribosome
we can imagine a ribosome that exists
solely of rna
right so we actually have a
bootstrapping mechanism because we know
right now you need a ribosome to make a
ribosome right which is not a very
but we know that you could bootstrap a
ribosome using only rna
yeah we can still see that we can see
that in the core of the ribosome
is an rna-only construct yeah and there
is evidence that it would work if you
take
if you would take out all the proteins
it would just be very slow it would
still work
yeah so we actually have an evolutionary
path how you would get to a functioning
ribosome
it's just that yeah we haven't seen it
right
right and and and we don't we don't have
a clear
idea of how rna
would have rna chains would have been
produced
and evolved without enzymes because
right now all of our
rna evolution experiments they require
enzymes so that that's one of the big
questions in origin of life is
what was rna you know you know i see
people obsessing over that that they
said yeah we haven't found this we
haven't found that yeah but
we also have not found that we will not
find it yeah
right uh it's it's it's a matter of
imagination there are no impossibilities
in there
it's just uh what is the path and how
would it happen
and uh what are the conditions so the
fact that we
we don't have an open and shut case uh
is not super relevant and i i am more
intrigued by the fact that we see that
within this ribosome there is this core
of rna
that could build a ribosome yeah because
that tells you that okay that
that's no accident that was that way and
that once the ribosome
existed it used itself to make itself
more efficient
stands to reason so the gene
people when the when when they looked at
it even before computer programmers
people assumed that the gene was some
kind of sort of functional unit
right and like like a program or a
function
or whatever and because we were human
beings uh
we the gene was known before the the
whole dna was sequenced and they
people said look because we're human
beings we must have a million genes
so even biologists can be quite
irrational on that front
so and then there's then we started
measuring it like well maybe we have a
hundred thousand genes
and and then later we found out that we
actually have less genes than a potato
and and that took a long while for
people to realize that
what you think of in terms as complexity
um
it's not like if you have a million
genes that you would be more a more
capable animal or a more capable
organism
or whatever and um and this this is a
sort of
the same thing that if you look at the
computer program and and it's like
really big
it doesn't mean that it's really good
right and typically it actually means
that it's not
and um what i find also very exciting is
that that
we have this like these 20 000 or 28 000
genes now
and um if you look at
at big organisms there are only a few of
them
that have done a house cleaning exercise
and one of them is a is a very very
um modest plant and
it floats on water and uh
and it's the most compact genome that we
know about
and and that's a whole plant and it
functions on like like
five percent of the dna that we have
really and
much like computer programmers are
always trying to find pieces of code
that are sort of minimal
but complete because we enjoy that we
enjoy having this
this tremendous concentration of
functionality without all the bloat
and in the same way we have these these
small plants that
offer sort of a whole organism but then
without
the 97 junk around it
and it doesn't mean it's junk but it
apparently means that you can get a
whole plant
out of it that functions and um remember
the species
yeah i can email it to you
i keep forgetting it so because we have
on the other hand uh
we have um oh it's so glorious
yeah um the amount of dna
so here on the left there's this this
plant the paris japonica plant which is
it's a pretty plant i mean don't get me
wrong yeah um
it has 10 times more dna than we do wow
and but that's it i mean it's a lovely
plant i i have to admit that but
you could look at it and um
and i tried to get one of these plants
for one of my presentations but it
because it's not biologically an
interesting plant and it's also not very
pretty
and uh and people it's not it doesn't
survive very well in in your house so
it's very tricky to get
to get one yeah uh but it's a pretty
plan but it somehow carries along 10
times more dna
than we have and yes and then there's
this fish on the right the marbled lung
fish which also has around 10 times more
dna than we do
so species i think it's a species of
mouse that has
four pairs of chromosomes instead of two
so yeah these these weird
doublings happen throughout evolutionary
history it turns out birds
and birds also uh mess a lot uh with
that stuff and they have different
rearrangements going on
and that's also one of the stranger
things if you really delve into dna then
you find that human dna is extremely
well studied
yeah for obvious reasons and then there
are a few
bacteria that are super well studied and
the zebra fish that you mentioned as
well we know
i mean if you care about your health
it's a very good idea to be a zebra fish
yeah because we know really everything
about zebra fishes
and um and then you you ask so i
recently got fascinated by birds
and i don't know i must be getting old
or something like that
and then you just try reading up what do
we know about bird genomes and they go
like
yeah yeah they have genes yeah uh
because like a crow the crowds are
utterly fascinating animals
but we know like 25 times more about
chicken dna
right than because yeah it's a big
business
and no one makes any money from kraus
so there are a lot of history there are
a lot of mysteries and that one that's
one of the reasons also why i promote
this whole dna stuff
that it could use a lot more attention
right and and because of the way the
world is structured with open data
and all the processing power that people
now have at home
people that are good with data systems
could really for example
improve the state of the chicken genome
or the crowd genome
and that's not the chicken genome
because there's a lot of
commercial effort focused on that but if
you and i would say
we would say hey we're going to study
the crowd genome we could download the
stuff and we could create a
scientifically relevant paper
in two months really and it would
further the state
of the understanding of kraus simply
because right now
not that many people are looking at them
but you don't need to be this
you don't need this 20-year track record
of biology
in order to advance the state of
understanding of crowd dna you had an
animation of the ribosome doing its
thing
that was really cool yeah it is i think
it's
this one but it's mmm
yeah so here we see the ribosome
that's the little black chain going
through it that's the messenger rna
coming into the transfer rnas bringing
amino acids to the ribosome
and the those transfer rnas are
attracted to the
codons in the messenger rna so every
three letters
of the messenger rna attracts a specific
transfer rna
and you're seeing the new protein that's
being built is just starting to peek out
the top there
and what is that like black that's the
new protein
now it's being attached to a
cell membrane so that it can excrete
that protein
into a chamber that's being built but
yeah that ribosome the core of the
ribosome
is identical in all organisms a lot of
the
the outer bits of it are unique to you
know
bacteria versus archaea eukaryotes
there's a lot of unique parts but the
core is identical which
is quite spectacular it is i mean if you
if you want to focus on sort of the
magic
uh this is definitely where the magic
happens yeah
and um and even and in one sense it's
very identical but in the other sense
there are these
small changes so for example in our
mitochondria
which are the little bacteria that live
within our cells to provide us with
energy so
yeah thank you bacteria they
they run their own ribosome and they
have their own transfer rna
and it's all very minimal because the
the way it evolved is that everything
that
we could share with that little tame
bacterium
was actually taken out of it and is part
of the nucleus of our normal
dna so the only thing that is left in
the mitochondrial
structure is stuff that it really cannot
do without
yeah and so there you find
a really minimal system and
what is really fun is that that even if
you take everything away
you cannot take away the transfer rna
because if you have no transfer rna you
are not you're not an organism you're
not doing anything
so if you look at the tiny dna of the
mitochondria that consists mostly of
23 transfer rnas because it has to have
one for every
amino acid right and that's a
functionality that it could not
do away with so the the the the dna of
the mitochondria really
consists mostly of the the table stacks
of how
how can i be a minimal organism yeah
yeah and then there are a few
mitochondrial bits
left
[Music]
i'm curious how important
claude shannon's work has been to the
field of programming actually
i've gotten mixed messages from people
some people say
well what he did was mostly for uh
engineering
and other people are saying no what he
did was he really described what a
communication system is
and that helped us kind of pull away
from
communication systems as we knew already
we'd already invented telephones and so
on
and we realized we could build the
communication system out of anything
and so the computer is just a diverse
collection of different communication
systems and
different ways to translate languages
from one system into another
and yeah i'm curious what your thoughts
are on
on claude shannon's work yeah so the
people that that
doubts the importance to his field are
probably blinded
by the how humongous it was what he did
for the field
so some things are so big that that you
cannot see it's like standing next to
if you stand on a big mountain you might
not realize that you're standing on the
big mountain right
[Music]
if you look at the two most important
papers that shannon wrote
the first one was where he said look we
have this boolean logic thing
and you can turn that into circuits
electrical circuits
and you can perform logic with electrons
yeah
and that is the fundament of everything
that we do
yeah yeah it's it is like i said
it is so big that you might not see it
and
would someone else have chanced on that
eventually
of course someone else would have
chanced on that eventually yeah
uh but his paper and which is by the way
he graduated on that it's his thesis
yeah defined the whole field
and saved us like 20 years because he
not merely
raised the possibility i mean that's
that's the awesome thing about shannon
he did not merely raise i mean a typical
scientific paper will go like hey well
we
figured this out and uh yeah it might
this is what it works it might have the
following uses
right and that's where it ends and the
typical shannon paper and i've read a
few of them
reaches that point where it said well it
might have a few uses and then you think
the article will end here
and then it's when it gets going yeah
yeah and then it goes like well let me
define for you exactly
how all that is going to work and and
and the speeds you could achieve
and how the topology of that whole thing
would be
so i think that you could say that if
you look at that first paper the boolean
logic with integrated circuits
uh that not only proves that it's
possible but then tells you how to do it
which in itself would eventually have
happened but maybe 10 years later
or maybe 20 years later or not as well
in any case so that's the first paper
that is maybe not so relevant for
biology because it's it's not about
signals
the second one a theory of
communications does the same thing it
starts out with with
if you read it today that paper you will
read it and then you you will think yeah
this is a good introduction to the field
this is
nice thank you right and then oh wait
this defined the whole field
this before this was written it's not an
introduction it is
it is the the genesis of the field yeah
and
then i'll just give you but then
when you when you hit the end of the
introduction where you think oh this is
a good introduction
then the paper gets going yeah and it
describes to you the limits of
communications
and and even the concepts of entropy and
uh
where we can talk a lot about what why
he used the word entropy
but where he even says look there is a
degeneracy and information that
you could take out half the words of any
sentence i speak and it would still make
sense
right and then he describes the limits
on that stuff and that has very deep
biological significance again
yeah uh where you see that these the
many ways of writing codons
uh still survived but the redundancy in
there means that many
errors uh can be corrected
again right and so
um i think that paper really is the tour
de force that actually
shows you a lot of the signal and
information
content theory on how you can yeah
think about dna but this influence goes
beyond that because there's actually in
biology if you have an ecology of
all kinds of different organized
organisms living together
and you want to know is this a simple or
uh or a complex
ecosystem and that's actually called the
shannon complexity
yeah yeah so the whole number the very
number we have to discuss
ecologies is named after shannon because
he defined that stuff
yeah yeah um so yeah
so people were programming before
shannon so we had
we had all sorts of coding systems we
were doing communication in all
all sorts of different ways but
it am i right in saying that he he's the
one that really
helped us figure out what the heck we
were doing because we were doing it
before
but it it was like you get some mad
genius who
figured out a way to build this thing
and someone else who's just everyone
else is
just copying that and then
yeah the the framework for it because
it's a very concrete example when the
first transatlantic cable
was was laid uh people found out that
they could indeed
transmit voltages over that cable so you
could put five volts on one end and
eventually on the other end also a
voltage would come out
right but what they found is that in the
original transatlantic
cables the cable had a gigantic
electrical capacity
yeah that meant the moment you put five
volts on it it would take whole minutes
for the five volts to also appear on the
other end yeah
and people said there's something wrong
with the cable it is
it is it is uh it's not transferring the
voltage correctly but it was
transferring the voltage correctly it's
just that
in terms of signal capacity it was
rather useless
yeah because the bandwidth of the cable
was like a tenth or a hundredth
of a hertz yeah yeah and people were
massively frustrated over that they put
bigger and bigger voltages on the cable
to speed it up
but if you and it took like like five
years before someone realized what was
going on
anyone with even a cursory understanding
of shannon information theory would
immediately have said yeah
this is your channel yeah this is you
will never get more than one word an
hour
over this channel right because that is
the capacity of your channel
um so yeah before that we would just i
think before that we could only reason
about infinite capacity channels
yeah that were there but it simply was
not a factor
right and um and then afterwards then
now you could say well we know how much
information you can put
through this system and it's also not
going to be more than this ever
[Music]
so yeah i i i do think that we we uh
not there there are i mean the true mark
of excellence also
is if you invent something and then
a few decades later people
find your invention to be so
fundamentally part of the world that
they
no longer realize that it was an
invention
yeah that it's a it's a cruel punishment
but it's a cruel punishment that there
are now people on the internet that will
go out and yeah
yeah sure that makes sense take the
logarithm of the the signal to noise
ratio and
and then you multiply that by the
bandwidth and then you get the capacity
obvious yeah
well not it's it's kind of like
when you watch 2001 space odyssey it's
like this is just copying all the sci-fi
that i've ever seen
oh wait wait no no no everything else is
copying this
okay yeah or or even worse even worse
they they made that movie
before the first people went to space
right right
so so it's literally so it's by now you
go like from
yeah oh yeah that's a bit different than
that but uh
and good for its time and you realize
that it was it happened years before
anyone got launched into space yeah and
and
but if we go back to shannon he actually
wrote more words about biology because
he was also
he recognized that this was a very
fascinating system
and he also did research into artificial
intelligence and neurons
and other things and i think that there
there are people out there that cannot
deal with the concept that someone is
just
so much smarter and greater than you are
that you somehow have to belittle his is
his or her
achievements yeah that that then they
say
it's obvious it's obvious now i learned
that stuff in school
yeah you know why you learned that in
school
and and it's the same thing happens to
einstein people keep saying you know
einstein was wrong no
yeah maybe he was wrong in some places
but he was he was a giant of his fields
and and similarly we down the hall the
smartest people i know today
and is worrying don't hold a candle
to what the guy like shannon achieved
right and yeah i wonder why that is i
i mean sometimes i i think well maybe
yeah in biology it's it's darwin
who figured out i mean yeah he was
darwin was actually a very if you look
he was a very human person if you read
his uh his diaries he just
one day he wrote i hate everything and
every and everyone i'm not gonna do
anything today
right it's a very human thing and the
other thing about darwin is that he also
said look i'm not the smartest guy in
the world
right and interestingly enough he also
he was not
but he was the most dedicated person in
the world
and he did not let go and he was very
very methodical
yeah um one of the things you see in
biology
you get people that are really upset
that they they're working in darwin's
that they're working on the program that
darwin set up they want to
they want to you'll see people saying oh
darwin was wrong about this and look
evolution doesn't work how he says it
does like there's a
there's like a whole website of people
called the third way where they
they they just try and um put themselves
above darwin
and it's really interesting like people
don't want to just work in someone
else's
house that was built but you have these
these people in darwin's case i don't i
i think you're right
it wasn't he it's not that he was a
super genius it's that
the idea came it was time for this idea
to come about we had enough
background information this was just
gonna pop out of there
but with with shannon's work you have an
absolute genius who figured this stuff
out
but what he did is he opened the door so
wide that even
another genius like him is still just
going to be working on what he started
because because there's so much to do
within that
playground that he set up for us but
similarly
similarly people keep trying to prove so
there's this shannon
limit which is to say this is the amount
of information per second
you will get through this medium right
and it's like the light speed
yeah you will not break the speed of
light you will not break the shannon
limit
right still the whole world is full of
people that's
that that have found ways to sort of say
yeah but i did break the channel limit
yeah and and because for somehow it's
just a limit it's it's it's a challenge
that someone put there you're not going
to get beyond this
and that always makes people want to say
well i i will i will get beyond this
so so you're saying that that's kind of
like uh breaking the shannon limit is
like breaking the second law of
thermodynamics
yeah no one thinks the speed of light or
the the the perpetual mobility
yeah uh that gets people all riled up
and uh and of course with the the the
shannon limit for
for a very long time was also a
commercial thing because it's limited
this is the amount of information you're
going to get ever sent through this
copper
pair right and if you would be able to
beat that limit you would become very
rich
right and and we now know that you're
not going to beat that limit ever but
that did not stop a whole bunch of
charlatans
trying to make it happen so now now the
focus is on compression right
so you can press your data in ways or
simplify it
i yeah i had heard maybe maybe you know
about this too like
that microsoft word nobody
actually knows how it works anymore yeah
and there's a bunch of stuff that we
think is garbage but no one dares taking
anything out
and that's and that's that is exactly
true and uh and that is but you see the
same thing in life
uh there are probably parts of of
biology that many
many organisms have tried to take out
yeah and uh
no it doesn't work uh one of these for
example is a sexual
procreation right it turns out that
beyond a certain complexity
it's impossible not to do it right and
there are many organisms that have tried
it like
for example yeast yeast is a good
example that can
it's a complex organism but it can
procreate asexually
however occasionally it still does it
yeah and
and this turns out to be one of these
mysterious things that you cannot take
out and
and and survive for a very long time
yeah and
uh but microsoft word i mean i mean it's
a very
it's a microsoft word is in a sense what
happens if you leave a piece of
biology alone for for a few years and
then you see what
what happened in your fridge yeah and it
became a lot bigger and no one really
knows what it originally was
and which is why bacteria are
are so fascinating because bacteria have
this minimal dna
everything about the bacterium is
minimal because otherwise it would not
be there it would not survive
and that makes them a lot more fun to
study
in my eye at least than than studying
the humongous complexity that is even a
yeast cell
yeah you could a bacterium is within
striking distance of being a set of
algorithms yeah
and in the sense that you can also use
mathematics to predict their behavior
and they will
they will do that they will even there's
a beautiful experiment that you can run
in the petri dish where you set up two
two colonies of bacteria and they will
grow and in the middle where they meet
they form an interference pattern yeah
yeah
and and you can calculate the shape of
that interference pattern and they will
they will dutifully do it for you
wow and so i i i would
i they're and the the problem is and
that's one thing
there are aspects of biology that are
not present in bacteria
which is well for example uh many
uh animals are able to do a navigation
based on the polarization of light right
or magnetic fields
so so doves for example are able to do
magnetic navigation but we're not quite
sure how they do that
right and doves are not easy to
experiment on because they're rather big
and they
they poo and uh they're not nice to have
in
a lab but you know i tried very hard
because the lab where i worked
only did experiments on single-celled
things only been
no doves no fruit flies no zebra fishes
right only bacteria
so i hunted is there any bacterium that
is sensitive to magnetic fields
it turns out yes there is but they do it
they go by it in a very
uh biological way they eat some iron
yeah really and so there are actual
bacteria that do navigate using magnetic
fields but they do that because their
little pieces of iron actually just
point north
yeah which is which is not the exciting
thing like the
doves we know that when doves sends
magnetic fields they do that using
complicated quantum mechanical processes
that we do not understand
right we don't we don't get how dove
does what it does
right and um but one thing you could do
is you could try to take that piece of
uh
we know which genetic code the dove uses
for that
okay and it makes a protein called
cryptochrome
and we could take the dna from a dove
put that in the bacterium
and see if we could evolve a bacterium
that is sensitive to magnetic fields
yeah that would be a lot of fun yeah
because then you've got this minimal
minimal organism that you can study and
see if it's sensitive to magnetic fields
and then do all your experiments there
yeah oh yeah that would that would be
amazing yeah that would be fun but it's
sadly i have no biological lab at home
yeah
and uh yeah with covid most labs are
shut down right now yeah they have but
they have better things to do right now
yeah yeah they uh
and there's also a huge shortage of uh
materials
uh right now so and there are
experiments that you simply could not do
right now
uh because the materials are all doing
worthier things right now
yeah so for now this will remain a
thought experiment
well bird this was amazing this was a
this was a really
cool conversation i just i hope that
everyone can just realize how
how spectacular our bodies are
i mean we're the the inventions that
we're making we're thinking that we're
inventing them for the first time
and then we find something similar
somewhere in biology i mean even
i guess maybe uh you know wheels don't
exist on
animals but we do find things like
wheels at the biochemical level
i mean yeah everything so it's
it is just spectacular don't
don't let uh you know a fear of woo-woo
stop you from being just absolutely
mesmerized by
the beauty that is like maybe to end
this on a
richard feynman the big physicist and um
he's more controversial now than he used
to be but he still had some very great
insights and he said look the more i
know about the flower
the more i understand about what what
gives it its color and why it has its
color and how the color works
it doesn't reduce the beauty of the
flower in any way right it only makes it
prettier to me because now i know that
not only is it superficially a pretty
thing to look at but underneath there is
a whole
separate structure of beauty which i can
now also appreciate
yeah and in that way we can all yeah
appreciate nature more the more we know
about it
yeah yeah well thank you for coming on
stay curious everyone yeah
you